Pedro tiene una huerta con cierto número de naranjos.
El tuvo que cortar 5 árboles para controlar los insectos.
Cada uno de los árboles restantes produjo 210 naranjas,
la cosecha total fue de 41790 naranjas.
¿Cuántos árboles había inicialmente en
la huerta de Pedro?
Así que sea "a" lo que nos están preguntando,
el número de árboles inicialmente...
inicialmente...
así es que empieza con "a" árboles
pero nos dicen que tiene que cortar 5 árboles
para controlar los insectos,
así es que
¿cuántos árboles le quedaron después de eso?
Empezó con "a" y tuvo que cortar 5, así
es que le quedan "a" menos 5 árboles.
Ahora nos dicen, nos dicen aquí, cada uno
de los árboles restantes...
y sabemos que quedan "a" menos 5 árboles...
producto 210 naranjas, así es que cada uno
de estos "a" menos 5 árboles,
va a producir 210 naranjas.
Así es que, este es el número de naranjas
que "a" menos 5 árboles va a producir.
Este es el número de árboles, este es el
número de naranjas que produce cada árbol,
así es que este es el número de naranjas que se producen después de haber cortado 5 árboles.
Y nos dicen, que esto acaba siendo al final de cuentas, la cosecha total que fue de 41790 naranjas,
así es que esto es igual a 41790.
Ya hemos establecido nuestra ecuación, lo
único que tenemos que hacer es resolver para
"a", el número de árboles que Pedro tenía originalmente.
Lo primero que podemos hacer aquí es multiplicar
por 210 estos términos que tenemos aquí
o no, también podemos dividir
entre 210 toda la ecuación.
Hay varias maneras de hacer esto, una sería
distribuir el 210 aquí en el "a" y el 5
y la otra sería, dividir toda la ecuación entre 210.
Voy a hacerlo de las dos maneras.
Primero voy a dividir entre 210, ambos lados
de la ecuación, del lado izquierdo estos
términos se cancelan y nos queda tan solo
"a" menos 5 y del lado derecho
es 41790 entre 210, ¿y esto cuánto nos da?
Necesitamos hacer la división, 41790 entre
210, veamos.
4, no podemos dividir entre 210, 41 tampoco,
417 entre 210 es 1, pues 2 por 210 es 420,
1 por 210 es 210 ,que restamos, restando 210
de 417 nos quedan, 207, bajemos ahora el 9,
2079 entre 210, esto es 9 porque si fueran
10 serían 2100, 9, 2079 entre 210 es 9,
vamos a multiplicar por 210, tengo que hacerlo poco
a poco, 9 por 0 es 0, 9 por 1 = 9,
9 por 2 =18, y vamos a hacer esta resta, tenemos
que 0 para 9 es 9 y ahora, para continuar
la resta vamos a suponer que de estos dos
millares pasamos 1 como 10 centenas
y nos queda tan solo 1 millar y ahora, de las 10
centenas, vamos a dejar 9 centenas
y vamos a pasar, se va a convertir en 10 decenas,
para que tengamos 17 decenas,
ahora, 9 para 17 es 8 y luego, 8 para 9 es 1 y 1 para 1
es 0, nos queda 189, vamos a bajar entonces
este 0 que tenemos aquí...
bajamos este 0 que tenemos aquí
y 1890 ya vimos que es 9 por 210 así es que aquí nos
queda 9, 9 por 210 es 1890,
hacemos la resta y nos queda, un residuo de 0.
Así es que del lado derecho obtenemos 199...
199...
el lado derecho entonces es 199 y
¿qué nos queda?
Sumamos 5 a ambos lados para despejar a "a"...
sumamos 5 a ambos lados,
recuerda que hay que hacerlo para ambos lados, tenemos una igualdad
a la cual estamos sumando un mismo
número a ambos lados...
Entonces el lado izquierdo nos resulta "a",
tan solo "a"...
déjame ponerlo en el mismo color púrpura...
nos queda "a", se han cancelado los 5
que es igual a 199 más 5 es 204 árboles.
Dijimos que había varias maneras de hacer
esto, en vez de haber dividido aquí entre
210, podríamos haber distribuido este 210
en "a" menos 5, vamos a hacer eso.
Vamos a ponerlo aquí abajo.
Esto sería entonces 210 por "a"...
"210a" menos 210 por 5...
menos 210 por 5...
210...
no, voy a hacer de hecho el producto de una vez...
210 por 5, esto es 1050...
menos 1050 y esto es igual a 41790.
Sumamos ahora 1050 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
sumando 1050 a ambos lados, ¿qué nos resulta?
Es 1050, no 150... 1050...
Ahora sí, hacemos la suma, del lado izquierdo
esto se cancela, nos queda "210a"
y del lado derecho haciendo la suma, ¿cuánto nos da?
0 más 0 = 0...
0... 9 y 5 = 14 y llevamos 1, 1 y 7 = 8 y
0 = 8, 1 y 1 = 2, 42840, dividiendo ahora
entre 210 ambos lados de la ecuación, vamos
a dividir entre 210 ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y ahora, ya sabemos a donde vamos a llegar,
podríamos hacer la división larga de 42840
entre 210, pero ya sabemos que
el valor de "a" es igual a 204.